hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde gibt wie heißt
die scheiße irgendwie zocker ist derzeit
wieder jeder minecraft youtuber und da
ich ja irgendwie immer noch so ein
bisschen minecraft in meinem herz habe
aufrecht gehalten wurde aber ich mir
gedacht ich muss das ganze noch mal
spielen und es gibt glaube ich in 30
sekunden wieder tat ich wollte das jetzt
heute mal an diesem freitag minecraft
tag mal so ein bisschen als unterlegt
gameplay das ist eigentlich ganz nett
keiner erkennt mich aufgrund von meinem
neuen namen fest ich mitbekommen hat
mein neuer name lautet ich verlinke euch
einfach das video hier da habe ich alles
alles mögliche da erklärt schaut euch
das einfach an ich kenne den spielmodus
nur aus videos von meinen kumpels max
und seppel mehr gaming schaue ich in
deutschland eigentlich nicht man was
soll denn das wiso box der mich denn ich
bin profi warum alle get on jump dings
maps die ich mal gesehen habe waren so
dass man direkt drin ist und jetzt bin
ich einfach auf einem baum was ist das
denn falls ihr diesen spielmodus nicht
kennt der ist total banal man muss quasi
einfach runter springen und darf dabei
nicht sterben
das ist es ich wollte das heutige video
einfach mal nutzen um so ein bisschen
kann ich den hier als auch wieso kann
ich bin kein unterschlagen
doch jetzt geklappt ich wollte das video
jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen nutzen
um über so ein paar dinge was ist das
lucky scheiße blödmänner hier ich wollte
über die in den hack vorfall noch mal
kurz reden weil mir es ist örtlich auf
das video wo ich sage was mein neuer
account es hat irgendwie nach einem tag
oder zwei tagen eine halbe million
aufrufe gemacht und das zeigt mir also
ich habe mein halbes herz und auch daran
dass ich da nein
auch die tatsache dass ich zu diesem
thema täglich ca 50 trillionen da ist
ein absorption was ist das wasser etwas
habe ich habe extra herzen und mcfit
pumpe hat also mag ich nicht den modus
jetzt falle ich gerade einfach durch
durch also irgendwie bin ich auch das
sei eigentlich bin ich
aber irgendwie kommt das nicht zu sehr
zum vorschein ich bin vom vom server
geflogen
du bist noch für fünf minuten aus den
mini games gebrannt da du eine runde
verlassen hast
ich wurde gekickt dann laufe ich jetzt
hier erst mal kurz noch ein bisschen rum
bevor ich wieder in die runde john kann
über was ich reden wollte war einfach
weil es quasi sucht so viele leute haben
sie damit beschäftigt und ich bin
dankbar ich habe total viele nachrichten
um mails von euch bekommen wo ihr
beigestanden gehabt und gesagt hat haye
luca wird schon wieder sei nicht traurig
und sogar mein netzwerk hat einigen
einige mails bekommt wo leute auch
geschehen beim hey wir wollen nicht
unterstützen falls es noch nicht
mitbekommen wir konkreter sein account
gehackt danke ich finde sowas ultra
aufmerksam und finde es einfach nice
dass ihr mir da so ein bisschen unter
die arme greifen wir noch sehr viele
angeboten sich den account zu holen und
ihn dann an mich weiter zu geben einige
wollten ihnen auch an mich verkaufen für
fünfstellige summen eine der absurdesten
nachrichten nicht bekommen hat war von
einer person namens oder irgendwie so
und der meinte jan luca du kannst nichts
dagegen tun man kennt mich schon ich
hätte den ein oder anderen minecraft
server und ich werde auch mich direkt
call crafter nennen
ich dachte mir dabei natürlich erstmal
nichts und er kam dann danach allerdings
noch in der zweiten mailen tag später an
wenn du willst kannst du mir dann aber
den namen für 15.000 euro abkaufen habe
ich gesagt okay ich habe heute noch mit
dem mojang support geschrieben und habe
den gegenseitige zeigte auch guck mal
das ist wirklich mein kanal ich habe mir
neue count extra broich gekauft könnt
ihr mir nicht irgendwie den namen
zurückgeben und die meinten wirklich ja
das kriegen wir hin studio 71 ist noch
über microsoft direkt gegangen das ist
aber ein bisschen keine ahnung was das
war mir dann schon voll krass irgendwie
so direkt über microsofts zu gehen und
dann weiter halte schon den kontakt mit
dem mojang support und dann hat er ein
netter typ damit hampus harmlos haben
vivid irgendwas mit oder fritz gibis
doch wir denken
die mini games gewarnt hatte der eine
relevante night in diesen engen
jedenfalls muss sich diesen typen von
mojang ein paar daten von mir schicken
die beispielsweise die transaction
transaction trend transaction triptrap
transaktions id dann auch so was wie die
letzten vier ziffern von der mastercard
echtes gekauft habe und so weiter und so
fort zu ein paar sachen einfach um mich
zu identifizieren er meinte dann solo
alles klar ich leite es weiter du
kriegst vielleicht kann sein dass der
mich kennt oder die kümmern sich darum
dass ich meinen namen zurück kriege und
zwar einfach dementsprechend dass sie
mir diesen account quasi wieder
wegnehmen und dann als namen einfach
wieder kontrakte einspeichern weil sie
gesehen haben dass das ja wirklich ich
bin tot sie haben gesehen dass das
wirklich ich bin und wollen wir deswegen
auf diesen account hier quasi dann
wieder meinen namen zurück buchen oder
irgendwie so leute wie tui hobby los
können leute sein und sagen ja hier ich
dich nehmen da wurde ein account und
hektisch und 15.000 jetzt schön heißt
dual-core straftat nämlich die 15.000
euro legte nach stecken und damit du dir
meinen namen da wieder geben kannst ich
will mit ich bin profi elias zufrieden
das war es eigentlich schon vorüber ich
heute reden wollte
und ja freunde als wir brauchen wir
jetzt keine sachen mehr per mail
das war knapp brauchen jetzt keine mails
mehr schreiben mit jan luca hier wir
schaffen das schon alle also das ist
ultra lieb von euch aber das ist echt
und dem checkpoint das muss nicht
unbedingt sein und guck mal der gewinner
ist das heißt ich hab auch gewonnen
trotzdem danke für euren kompletten zug
das ist falls dieses klatschen macht und
mittlerweile da bist du direkt zum video
vorbei eigentlich gar nicht mich schon
verpissen trotzdem danke für eure ganze
support in den kommentaren nur durch die
ganzen mails ich dir jetzt dass ich
komplett über lichtet bin weil die
softbox komplett anders und ich den
schwarzen rudi jahren habe der im shop
ich glaube es ist eher ausverkauft ich
bin derzeit nicht mehr so auf dem lukasz
ob wir kümmern uns darum neue designs
und was alles und um richtig nasse
sachen also wir haben schon eine neue
stoff art ich zocke gerade übrigens
gerade die ganze zeit schon weiter aber
das ist ein anderes thema freunde sobald
ich meine count wieder zurück habe werde
ich das in minecraft video dann zeigen
und es gerade übrigens drei uhr nachts
und ich muss in dreieinhalb stunden
aufstehen ich habe übrigens seit
neuestem auch augenringe